[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
oppo find 5 has evolved a lot since i
first reviewed it earlier this year in
fact it's gotten almost constant
over-the-air updates straight from oppo
in fact if you go to oppo's google plus
page you can see pretty much a list of
the change log of all the updates and
the dates that they happen and they show
up on the phone and show up over the air
so in an attempt to maintain this as a
really high-end phone they've spent a
lot of time uh making sure this thing
gets constant update but the update i'm
about to show you guys has never been
seen before this is the first video on
the internet of it this is project
firefly on the oppo find five so if you
remember my samsung galaxy s4 features
explained video which will be the first
link below the like button if you don't
you'll remember that samsung has
basically discovered that adding
features to a phone via software has
been really successful compared to
adding features via hardware so a lot of
other companies have actually gotten on
board with this in fact htc has gotten
on board as you've seen the htc one and
all its various features htc happens to
name all of them various different
things
lg's also got unborn and followed sort
of in samsung's footsteps maybe a little
bit too much in samsung's footsteps they
pretty much copied samsung but a lot of
different companies are also on board
and oppo has pretty much figured out
that if this phone is going to be a
beast on the hardware side you might as
well make it awesome on the software
side too so they're also adding features
via software and they're taking a little
bit of a different approach but it's
definitely worth checking out i want to
preface this by saying that i'm showing
you guys a preview version of the
software not fully complete yet but
definitely coming soon so again this is
the first video you guys are seeing of
it take a look so first of all the whole
design and the user interface is nice
and fresh and clean and polished and
smooth uh kicks in point the settings so
i'll go ahead and show you the
notification bar here you can see
there's a new green and white theme
definitely good looking and you can see
the theme here but when we go into
settings and you can hear the new tap
sound
definitely pretty cool but you can now
swipe through your settings this is the
first like main step in the ability to
properly navigate a ton of settings on a
device like this i'll go ahead and swap
all the way down and you can see we're
running android version 4.1 if i go
ahead and view about phone here android
version 4.1 and you can still get more
system notifications and updates and
things like that but this is still the
same beast of a powerful phone that we
saw in the original review so there's a
lot of new animations now that you'll
see there's a lot of sliding through the
notifications for example if i go into
the messaging app and i want to hit menu
you can see it shifts up and it grays it
out just little things like that are way
more polished i hit back and you can see
it fades
deck down to nothingness just all the
different things about the animations
the way this works
are a lot more smooth and polished and i
definitely like the way the things
animate especially that little menu
animation i definitely dig that now i
did a couple of other little polished
things like the multitasking menu for
example you might remember was very
weird on the old one now you have a
similar menu but now it's similar to the
old style of android vertical scrolling
swipe out to remove applications and
even a clear button to clear all your
memory and remove all the programs so
you have free memory there's also a new
keyboard and like i said this isn't a
fully complete version but you'll see uh
the new keyboard theme which is a little
bit crazy but it's definitely new and i
don't like the way if if you change
things just to change it i don't usually
like that but if you change it to make
it better i tend to be a fan of that so
changing things
in here you can see the new animation
for swiping over
nice and fast all this stuff is
happening on a 1080p display battery
life is unaffected so i'm really
impressed with the overall polish level
that we've seen
but now for the added features first of
all this is cool full screen widgets
this is a full screen widget that i
added basically i hit the menu button
and it brought me to the all the
wallpapers and stuff that i'll go
through in a second but i added a full
screen widget and this is the photos one
and this is pretty cool so i added a
whole bunch of different photos that i
took basically i tapped here to start
taking pictures and you can see the live
camera down there and i take a new
picture and it adds it to my timeline
and there's a timeline here of all the
different photos that i've taken over
the course of an event and you can of
course edit or delete that photo so
that's a whole different
full screen widget that just takes over
the entire experience see the dock icons
they change to make sense with media so
this is a basically full screen media
widget there's another one cool here
called the music one which is really
awesome if i was using the stock music
player i could drag that on and start
playing music that is insane and the
graphics all are really crisp and
detailed because well this is a 1080p
display the phone takes full advantage
of it and it's nice and smooth and again
the dock icons change to work perfectly
with that there are even themes so i can
hit menu and go to the themes store and
hit more and it'll open up a store and
again it's not english completely yet
because it's still in the works but
there is a full on theme that you can
add to your device so a lot of people
are like oh well how do i get the apps
you have on your home screen or how do i
have that icon pack well oppo has its
own store where you can basically pick
an icon pack and set it as your default
and then all your home screen icons can
change so if you don't like the stock
ones that come with project firefly then
you can just pick one from the store a
lot of them are free some of them are
paid but i don't think i would ever pay
for any of them but you can grab one and
set that too again you can sit maybe
this one has my home screen here again
wallpapers they have some new wallpapers
in here as well and we have a section
called olab this is insane this is a
whole new level of interaction so let's
say i want a weather one and it's
raining outside and i kind of want to
set the mood i hit the rain button and
it changes the wallpaper and it adds a
live wallpaper rain effect doesn't
affect performance at all but now it is
raining on my home screen
let's try another one i like the snow
one because it was kind of snowing
recently so i'll go ahead and add snow
and it changes the wallpaper to snow and
it starts snowing on my icons and you
can see after a little bit snow actually
begins to accumulate on my dock icon so
there's frost and snow on my dock icons
that is crazy that is insane
and again performance is unaffected i
can still go in and out of apps and
multitask and use all this ram
effectively because it's a beast of a
phone that s4 pro powers everything but
now we have frost at the bottom here if
i ever want to go back i can change the
old lab stuff by turning it off
just like i go back to my wallpapers
here
and i'm going to go ahead and select a
photo i have and i'm going to go back to
the
firefly one and i can keep the firefly
one and keep having snow on my home
screen how sick is that so that's a
pretty incredible level of detail so if
you really want to get that immersive
experience i mean talk about adding
features that's something that some
average people will actually kind of
like but yeah so there it is guys that
is project firefly on the oppo find five
it is really really new now again this
is the first video on the internet that
you guys are seeing of it but it exists
now it's a project it's a thing and i
have faith that oppo is going to put a
lot of time and effort into making this
really really intense like making this a
very big part of selling the oppo find
5. so overall from all the different
things we've seen i like where this is
going this is definitely a step in the
correct direction this is a step in the
direction of improving phones that
you've already bought for free basically
by just pushing over the air update so
you can keep getting more and more
updates to this stuff directly from oppo
so props this is a neat trend i like it
keep going with it and hey if there's
anything else you guys want to see in
terms of added features via software
that hasn't been seen on any other phone
out there let me know in the comments
definitely give some ideas maybe alpha
will be the first one to pick it up and
you'll see it on the fine five first who
knows uh samsung could be watching as
google could be watching this motorola
htc who knows uh and go ahead and leave
your ideas below for things that you'd
want to see that haven't been added yet
either way thanks for watching and i
will talk to you guys in the very next
video
peace
[Music]
you